las delegaciones sueca y finlandesa
volaron ankara para las conversaciones a
tres bandas con turquía fueron recibidos
por el portavoz del presidente recep
tayib erdogán y su viceministro de
asuntos exteriores el objetivo de esta
reunión y de las siguientes es abordar
las preocupaciones de turquía en materia
de seguridad tras las solicitudes de
ingreso de finlandia y suecia a la otan
ankara acogió con satisfacción un primer
diálogo positivo
hemos visto una actitud positiva hacia
el levantamiento de las sanciones contra
los productores de la industria de
defensa en esta reunión es un tema
importante que podemos añadir a la
agenda positiva de la reunión
el tema del fin de las sanciones sobre
las armas es sólo una de las cinco
garantías concretas que ankara está
buscando específicamente por parte de
suecia las otras incluyen cooperación
global contra el terrorismo cese del
apoyo político al terrorismo eliminación
de la fuente de financiación del
terrorismo cese del apoyo armamentístico
al pkk y su rama siria diep eje en
estocolmo la primera ministra sueca dijo
que quería aclarar los malentendidos
durante las conversaciones con turquía
en su intervención
el presidente del consejo de la unión
europea charles michel magdalena'
anderson refutó las afirmaciones de
ankara de que suecia apoya grupos
militares kurdos
no enviamos dinero a organizaciones
terroristas por supuesto ni armas
turquía también exige la extradición de
unos 28 presuntos sospechosos de
terrorismo radicados en suecia y en
finlandia la lista de exigencias hace
que se desvanezcan las esperanzas de un
rápido ingreso en la otan para los dos
países nórdicos